GORDON RAMSAY (VOICEOVER):
It's the day of the final cook,
and I should be
getting my fires going.
Good morning.
WOMAN: Good morning, Gordon.
How are we?
Mrs. [inaudible], how are you?
GORDON RAMSAY (VOICEOVER):
But I have a lead on one
more special ingredient that I'm
told can be harvested nearby.
What is this secret ingredient?
[non-english speech]
She's making a chutney
out of the weaver ant.
It's a delicacy.
GORDON RAMSAY: Weaver ants?
WOMAN: Yes.
GORDON RAMSAY: Right.
WOMAN: Yeah.
It's spicy.
It's salty, and it's sour.
That sounds like
a unique chutney.
WOMAN: Yeah.
[inaudible]
And where are these ants?
Right up there.
That's what we were looking at.
GORDON RAMSAY: What?
WOMAN: [non-english speech]
OK, she says that he is
going to shimmy up that tree,
lop that branch off,
drop the ants down.
Right.
And fill it into
a-- a [inaudible]..
GORDON RAMSAY: Do we
have a rope for him?
This this-- is the ladder
that he's going to use.
GORDON RAMSAY: Ladder?
It's like a bamboo stick.
WOMAN: Yeah.
Be careful.
And are you sure that
bamboo is strong enough?
It's-- it's definitely
strong enough for him.
It's not even
tied onto the trees.
Bloody hell.
This is crazy.
I mean, really crazy.
[bleep]
WOMAN: There.
He is already on the tree now.
He's on the tree.
WOMAN: He's getting it.
GORDON RAMSAY: Wow.
Yeah.
[bleep]
WOMAN: They know the hills.
They know the jungles.
GORDON RAMSAY: Yes.
WOMAN: They're very,
very good at this.
GORDON RAMSAY:
That is incredible.
What a performance,
getting the ants.
I mean, you know,
I'll go to hell
and back, you know, to
get the best ingredients,
but that is a
different ballgame.
- [non-english].
- Thank you.
Good.
Oh, gosh.
Watch it, watch it, watch it.
Get it.
- Wait, wait, wait.
- Go, go, go, go.
Let me come left.
[bleep]
WOMAN: OK.
Can you go to the right?
No, no.
Come left.
WOMAN: [non-english]
GORDON RAMSAY
(VOICEOVER): I look
like I'm attempting the most
awkward TikTok dance ever.
[bleep]
Get it, get it, get it.
Damn.
[bleep]
Bloody hell.
- Hold it.
Hold it, hold.
That bag, you know, and
you're swaying left to right.
Bang.
I missed it.
Shake it up.
Shake.
Damn!
And then all of a sudden,
they're everywhere.
[bleep]
Man.
And just when you think
you've got the last one,
you put your hands in your
pockets, they're in there.
I must have been
bitten 50, 60 times.
[bleep] hell.
This is a true ants in
the pants situation, no?
This is definitely
ants in the pants.
[bleep]
- So there we are.
- Ah, you bastard.
[non-english speech]
- She's putting salt in this.
- Salt?
[bleep]
Yeah, we're
salting the ants now.
Yes.
[bleep]
- [inaudible]
- Yep.
You got to shake it up.
Those ants are eating
me before I eat them.
[non-english speech]
OK, that's enough.
[bleep].
I think I've got half
of the ants in my pants.
Bloody hell.
My goodness me.
WOMAN: So we just
pick out any dust.
Now, these little bits
there, the white bits--
that's the larva, right?
- That's the larva.
That's the-- that's the eggs?
Yeah.
GORDON RAMSAY (VOICEOVER):
While most of the ants
are making a meal
of my nether region,
the rest are getting
chucked into the chutney.
First, you have
to put the coconut--
- All?
- --in the [inaudible] coconut.
All the coconut?
Everything.
GORDON RAMSAY (VOICEOVER):
To make the chutney, we mix
coconut, garlic, salt,
coriander seeds, and, of course,
chili powder.
GORDON RAMSAY: All of it?
WOMAN: Yeah.
GORDON RAMSAY (VOICEOVER):
Then we add the ants,
some water, and grind.
Watch that you don't
smash your fingers.
Yeah.
[non-english speech]
You're doing good, she says.
Wow.
Mm.
It's delicious.
Oh, lovely.
GORDON RAMSAY: It's very fresh.
Yes.
Vibrant chutney.
I love chutneys.
That, for me, has to be the
most fragrant, slightly bitter,
but with the addition of
that coconut meal in there--
mm, delicious.
What a delicacy, and,
for me, a great addition
to my final meal.
I don't think these ladies are
expecting that from me today,
so a little ace card up my
sleeve, fingers crossed.